Which one of the following Endo Parasite of
Human does show Vivi Party and Kylo Stoma
Entero Bias Trike Nila and Ascaris Let us
tell you the correct answer
A is correct for Rakesh also What will be your answer
son pay here That is your C option That is
Your Trican Spiralis is fine, it is
not given in NCRT, I
know this, you people may not know this, what is yours, your
SK is an example of Hellmans, what does
yours do, it shows viviparity inside human,
how are your parasites?  Ovi perus are right they are
egg penis but if you talk about trike nella
then how is that yours that is a
vivi perus right ascaris son ascaris egg
take and chylo stoma entero
bias all what does egg take  Animals
are ok yes but this was asked in your previous year it
is datchi